general hd generalinspekteur der
bundeswehr von 2000 bis 2002 und dann im
anschluss vorsitzender des
nato-militärausschusses das höchste
militär amt im verteidigungsbündnis ich
begrüße herzig herrn quartal kujat vor
ein paar tagen sagten sie noch die
ukraine werde ganz schnell fallen warum
lagen sie da so falsch
wir sehen nicht nur dass die
ukrainischen streitkräfte sich sehr
wirksam verteidigen wir sehen vor allen
dingen erhebliche defizite auf der
russischen seite
der angriffsschwung hat deutlich
nachgelassen das liegt daran dass es
offensichtlich große versorgungsprobleme
gibt insbesondere bei der
treibstoffversorgung es kommt hinzu dass
ja auch die russischen streitkräfte nun
seit wochen und monaten
in manövern waren also eine gewisse ein
gewisse
ermüdungserscheinung hier auch schon
besteht insgesamt muss ich sagen dass
trotz allem die situation ja nach wie
vor ungeklärt ist wie dieser krieg
ausgehen wird aber es sie haben recht es
ist in der tat für viele und auch für
mich überraschend zu sehen dass die
diese dieser angriff so verläuft wie er
im augenblick läuft nämlich überhaupt
nicht erfolgreich es sind ja
waffenlieferungen angekündigt diverse
nato-staaten haben waffenlieferung
angekündigt deutschland hat sie
angekündigt und die eu will jetzt auch
kriegsmaterial ankaufen und das alles in
die ukraine schicken geht das überhaupt
in der momentanen situation wie gelangen
die waffen dort überhaupt hin
naja das ist das ist eben die frage es
muss sichergestellt werden dass die
waffen jetzt sehr schnell geliefert
werden denn niemand kann vorhersagen wie
sich die lage dort weiter entwickelt
also im
negativsten fall fallen die waffen sogar
in die hände der russischen streitkräfte
also das schön aber lassen sie mich
zunächst mal sagen ist ist jetzt ganz
wichtig in dieser sicht aktion dass
tatsächlich die
ukrainische widerstandskraft weiter
gestärkt wird ich war nicht ein
befürworter von waffenlieferungen
solange noch eine chance bestand einen
krieg zu verhindern weil waffen in der
regel zu einer weiteren eskalation
beitragen
jetzt sieht die situation völlig anders
aus jetzt hat russland den anruf
begonnen jetzt muss die ukraine sich
verteidigen und jetzt müssen wir schnell
handeln
es gibt heute morgen meldungen dass es
wohl auf bildern russischer seite auch
überlegungen gibt in den krieg
einzugreifen wenn das der fall wäre
würde das die lage in der ukraine aber
auch die geostrategische situation in
osteuropa noch mal komplett verändern es
gibt widersprüchliche nachrichten es
gibt diese nachricht und es gibt aber
auch die nachricht dass lukaschenko
selbst zur mäßigung rät also in einer in
einem krieg wie in diesen muss man immer
sehen dass er auch von einem
informationskrieg
überlagert wird das wird immer wieder
versuchte verwirrung auf der seite des
gegners zu
entstehen zu lassen es werden die eigene
erfolge hochgelobt und das werden die
niederlagen des gegners vergrößert man
muss wirklich versuchen einen klaren
blick zu haben behalten und darf dabei
nicht jede aktion auf die goldwaage
legen ich denke wir müssen abwarten vor
allen dingen wie die gespräche heute
verlaufen ob es tatsächlich zu einem
waffenstillstand kommt oder vielleicht
sogar zu friedensverhandlungen
das wäre natürlich die beste lösung die
man im augenblick erreichen können sie
sagt man soll nicht jeder aktion auf die
goldwaage legen wladimir putin hat
gestern die sogenannten
abschreckungskräfte in alarmbereitschaft
versetzt ist das was worüber wir uns
noch mehr sorgen machen müssen jetzt
allerdings wenn sie die gesichter der
beiden generäle die neben ihm saßen also
das verteilt ministers und des
generalstabchefs gesehen haben dann
haben sie auch gesehen dass die reaktion
dort erstaunt war überraschung war also
offensichtlich war diese aktion gar
nicht mit seinen mitarbeitern
abgesprochen sondern es war eine einsame
entscheidung die putin getroffen hat und
sie ist darauf zurückzuführen dass sich
die dinge eben nicht so entwickeln wie
sie geplant waren und wie er es erwartet
hatte dass den ein aspekt haben wir ja
eben schon angesprochen nämlich dass der
angriffe an schwung verloren hat dass
der widerstand groß ist dass die
versorgungsprobleme auf russischer seite
ebenfalls groß sind aber es kommt auch
hinzu dass sie unter den internationalen
stütze unterstützung auf die putin
gehofft hatte also von seiten chinas
indiens ja auch von weißrussland nicht
so eingetreten ist das sehen sie an der
abstimmung dem abstimmungsverhalten
chinas in der in den sicherheitsrat der
vereinten nationen
wir wissen auch dass der chinesische
staatspräsident
zu mäßigung und zur einstellung des
angriffs geraten hat aber es kommt noch
etwas anderes hinzu ich finde das ist
ganz wichtig das sollten wir nicht
übersehen es gibt in der russischen
bevölkerung einen erheblichen widerstand
es gibt demonstrationen in großer zahl
und diese demonstrationen nehmen zu je
länger dieser krieg dauert und das ist
in einem repräsentiere press even system
wie in russland natürlich ein wagnis für
die bevölkerung zeigt aber auch die
entschlossenheit der menschen gegen
diesen bruderkrieg der dann und das ist
es ja aus russischer sicht einzutreten
ich bin sogar der überzeugung da und ich
habe gründe dafür dass es auch im
offizierskorps der russischen
streitkräfte erhebliche vorbehalte gegen
diesen krieg gibt man sieht also putin
steht relativ isoliert da auch in
russland und das ist auf der ist
natürlich ein risiko und das führt dann
auch zu solchen spontanen
ausbrüchen wie wir sie gestern erlebt
haben mit der androhung der die nuklear
streitkräfte in einer alarmbereitschaft
zu versetzen ähnliches hatte er vor zwei
tagen ja auch schon angekündigt das
müssen wir wirklich sehr sehr ernst
nehmen
denn die damit verbundenen risiken die
sind enorm ja sehr ernst genommen wird
die internationale situation das haben
wir ja auch gestern im bundestag gesehen
wie überrascht sind sie das ist so eine
180 grad wende gibt in der deutschen
verteidigungspolitik rüstungsexporte in
krisengebiete und jetzt 100 milliarden
für die bundeswehr hat sie das gestern
sehr überrascht das hat mich sehr
überrascht ich habe nicht gewagt zu
hoffen dass wir diesen negativen kurs in
unserer sicherheitspolitik den wir 2011
mit der sogenannten neuausrichtung der
bundeswehr eingeschlagen haben also weg
von der landes- und bündnisverteidigung
hin nur zu auslandseinsätzen mit enormen
auswirkungen auf unsere fähigkeit ein
beitrag zur landes- und
bündnisverteidigung zu leisten dieser
schritt den bundeskanzler scholz gestern
getan hat der wahrscheinlich für sehr
viele überraschend war ist wirklich eine
ein historischer schritt für deutschland
es muss natürlich jetzt abgewartet
werden ob tatsächlich mit dem gleichen
elan wie diese absicht verkündet wurde
auch die umsetzung erfolgt und zwar
schnell erfolg substanziell erfolg und
uns in die lage versetzt wieder zu einem
bündnispartner zu werden der einen
wesentlichen beitrag unserer größe
entsprechen wesentlichen beitrag zur
gemeinsamen sicherheit des bündnisses
leisten können ja ich spreche weiter mit
harald kujat general ag und auch
generalinspekteur der bundeswehr von
2000 bis 2002 sie haben ja erfahrung mit
beschaffung oder auch mit fehlender
beschaffung wie lange dauert es denn
wenn man jetzt dieses geld tatsächlich
bekommt die 100 milliarden euro bis die
bundeswehr wieder einsatzbereit ist wie
man es gerne hätte und wie es auch sein
muss anscheinend das liegt nicht primär
ich denke man kann durchaus von diesem
geld zunächst mal die lücken stopfen und
die sind ja in ihrem bericht
angesprochen worden die bevorratung
erhöhen mit material wir müssen das sind
nato vorgaben kampf material also
munition und ähnliches für 30 tage
intensiv einsatzbereit halten dass es
überhaupt nicht der fall das kann
natürlich relativ schnell geschehen aber
damit ist die bundeswehr noch nicht in
der lage ihren kernauftrag die landes-
und bündnisverteidigung zu erfüllen nein
es muss jetzt ein
grundlegender wandel eine grundlegende
reform durchgeführt werden und zwar sehr
schnell
dir das was
2011 eingeleitet wurde und in die
falsche richtung ging also weg von der
landes- und bündnisverteidigung hinzu
auslandseinsätze das muss jetzt
korrigiert werden und das bedeutet es
muss der personalumfang vergrößert
werden es muss die struktur verändert
werden hin auf landes- und
bündnisverteidigung wieder auch auf
aufwuchs fähigkeit wir müssen in der
lage sein reservisten zu integrieren
relativ schnell wenn es tatsächlich
ernst wird es muss die ausrüstung
korrigiert werden und die kann ja auch
nur im wesentlich korrigiert werden wenn
die nötigen strukturen zur aufnahme da
sind und es muss natürlich auch die
bewaffnung und die ausbildung geändert
werden das heißt also es muss sie es
sehr sehr schnell das geschehen was die
koalition ja angekündigt hat eine
nationale sicherheitsstrategie die
verteidigungspolitischen richtlinien von
2011 die diesen
negativen kurs eingeleitet haben müssen
aktualisiert werden auf die neue lage
angepasst werden die konzeption der
bundeswehr muss geändert werden relativ
schnell und dann muss das ganze
umgesetzt werden das kann man schaffen
also den sozusagen den konzeptionellen
über bauch kann man durchaus in zwei bis
drei monaten geschaffen das ist möglich
und dann muss natürlich die umsetzung
relativ schnell erfolgen es wird immer
wieder auf das
umständliche komplizierte beschaffungs
system hingewiesen dass sei also der
eigentliche hinderungsgrund es ist
richtig unser beschaffungs system ist
veraltet es ist nicht mehr zeitgemäß
aber das ist nicht der entscheidende
punkt der entscheidende punkt ist dass
man ausgehend von der neuen
sicherheitspolitischen lage von der
bedrohung die wir heute alle in europa
erleben die bundeswehr von grund auf
reformiert wird und das so schnell wie
möglich ja wir haben das thema material
auch angesprochen angesichts dieser
tatsache dass das alles schnell gehen
muss dass man ja auch geld einsparen
will machen da eigentlich so teure
europäische rüstungsprojekte wie
beispielsweise bei kampfflugzeugen macht
das überhaupt noch sinn man hätte ja
flugzeuge beispielsweise schon längst in
den usa kaufen können die perfekt
ausgerüstet sind und auch für die
verhältnisse hier in europa bestens
geeignet sind na ja man darf jetzt nicht
alles über den haufen werfen über
europäische rüstungsprojekt sind wichtig
wir müssen uns an technologie eine
technologie basis auch in deutschland
erhalten die es uns erlaubt auch in
verschiedenen bereichen anschluss an der
am technologischen fortschritt zu
behalten das halte ich für ganz ganz
wichtig wir dürfen nicht nur sozusagen
alles einkaufen
nein wir müssen auch fähig sein mit dem
fortschritt schritt zu halten
aber wenn sie ganz konkret die frage
ansprechen was brauchen wir an als
nachfolgesystem für den tornado dann
würde ich persönlich auch dazu arten die
f35 zu kaufen diese lösung die da an mit
der f 18 das sind das sind dinge die
wirklich uns nicht weiterbringen wir
müssen so modern wie möglich ausgerüstet
sein so leistungsfähig wie möglich das
bedeutet nämlich auch dass wir den
enormen finanziellen
aufwand für die material erhaltung über
die zeit reduzieren können das
verhältnis bei uns zwischen den
betriebskosten und in investiv kosten
ist so ungünstig zu und zu ungunsten der
investiv kosten insbesondere deshalb
auch weil wir eben veraltetes material
haben veraltete waffensysteme die einen
enormen aufwand erfordern auf
finanziellen aufwand erfolg also immer
da wo es möglich ist oder wo es
notwendig ist sollte ich besser sagen
schnell
technologisch hochwertige systeme zu
kaufen sollten wir uns nicht scheuen die
auch in den vereinigten staaten zu
kaufen aber wir sollten uns auch die
technologische basis für
für die eigene entwicklung erhalten das
halte ich für sehr wichtig bei einem
wort von ihnen habe ich nochmal auf
gehorchte hatten sie gesagt der
personalumfang der bundeswehr muss
erweitert erhöht werden sind sie dafür
dass es eine wehrpflicht wieder gibt
eine allgemeine
ich war immer ein befürworter der
wehrpflicht und ich habe es sehr
bedauert dass die wehrpflicht ausgesetzt
wurde im de facto ist sie ja abgeschafft
worden und zwar mit
begründungen die nicht den tatsachen
entsprach das muss man ganz klar sagen
aber in der gegenwärtigen situation
denke ich oder in der entwicklung die
wir auch durchgemacht haben
würde ich doch für eine berufsarmee
plädieren auch wenn sie erheblich teurer
ist auch das ist ja ein kostenfaktor
aber der personalumfang muss erhöht
werden und zwar nicht dadurch dass wir
uns
lösungen wählen die nicht zur kampfkraft
beitragen wie also ein verkürzter
freiwilliger wehrdienst von einigen
monaten nur wo die soldaten
rein und rausgehen können wann immer sie
wollen sondern wirklich mit einem festen
bestand von berufs und zeitsoldaten
der und diese berechnung haben wir schon
im jahre 2000 mindestens
200.000 mann umfassen muss ich würde
unter den gegenwärtigen bedingungen
sogar für einen größeren personal auch
umfang plädieren und das ist ja auch ein
ganz entscheiden wir sprechen immer über
waffensysteme über veraltete
waffensysteme aber die waffensysteme
müssen hier auch bedient werden und dazu
brauchen wir
motiviertes leistungsfähiges personal in
der bundeswehr und noch ein hinweis der
ganz eng zu sehen ist im zusammenhang
mit dem personal und umfang die struktur
muss aufnahmefähig gestaltet werden auch
für reservisten das heißt wir müssen uns
auch ein leistungsfähiges reservisten
potenzial erschaffen so dass wir im
gesamtumfang der streitkräfte im falle
dass wir uns verteidigen müssen oder
dass wir ein weiterer zur
bündnisverteidigung leisten müssen noch
über den paares umfang der bundeswehr
deutlich vergrößern können so war das
auch in der vergangenheit wir sollten
uns daran erinnern dass im kalten krieg
die krieg stärke der bundeswehr etwa das
dreifache an personal betrug was der
friedens umfang tatsächlich war und so
in etwa müsste es auch jetzt wieder
laufen von einer geringeren basis aus
war aber doch im verhältnis sollte dann
der verteidigungs umfang etwa dass
gerade das dreifache dessen sein was die
frieden stärke der bundeswehr ausmacht
das war ein einschätzung von harald
kujat general ag hat herzlichen dank für
das interview gerne alles gute